hey call collectors welcome to First
Noel auctions of the Bronx my name is
Noel come inside the very first car
believe it or not was a Shelby 1966
Shelby was doing the very first car
aboard when we're little boys we love
cars and it's just something that's
embedded with it's just playing with
cars and so as boys become men they
carried that same infatuation with them
and just that our cars have simply
changed from that of toys of boys to be
in toys of grown adults while I was
doing construction I was walking down
the street one day and I happened to
notice a guy that was standing next to
his car and I saw for sale signs on the
car it was just an average car on the
side of the street and he was out there
talking to them next day I sort of call
was gone and I saw another one was
sitting there eventually one day I
called him up cuz I saw a car I liked
and when I spoke to him on a 40 told me
that was sold to this guy is just like
flipping these cars like left and right
I thought to myself I could do that but
I still had a job and when I went to my
job one day he told me I had to fire I
got my severance check which was only
$200 and went to a car lot where a guy
was offering off of 500 bucks I took
that car I put it on the boulevard next
to the stoplight and I roll for sale and
I put my phone number on it two days
later a woman called me up on Monday and
I made more money and that vehicle then
I would have made in three weeks of
working doing construction it was
history after that I just was in the car
business from that day forward